[Music]  good morning wife  [Music]  because this is gray look out your  window why you know I'm taking you away  for the weekend I just can't believe  this is my life then I get to live with  you  that meant nothing to me before you Anna  Gray's office we wanted to welcome the  new fiction editor  I bought it for us I should have asked  you first oh my god Christian this is  Jim Matteo the architect this location  is perfect I'm going to build you a  fabulous house please stop speaking of  my husband as if I weren't here and you  may call me mrs. gray I'll pick you up  the fire I may not be done by then  we're being followed  how the hell are you Anna  Jack what do you want  so you want to play yes sir  I made a vow to love you faithfully for  safety all others did you sleep with her  to comfort you when times in need and to  keep you safe first long as we both  shall laugh  you